film and i just kept thinking like you
know
you're not as young as you were like i
wasn't young when i started
but i like what will make what will it
take to make you stop
i don't know really the big old oh
[Applause]
he gets too old to do the stunts right
or something that won't happen for years
so just enjoy yourself
joan all i can do is stand in one spot
or hold on to something because i'm so
uncoordinated i can do that at any age
anybody can get into it and it's funny
you can get into a pool and fart and
make bubbles thank you and as you get
older trust me it'll get easier
it's going to be okay
physically physically you do put
yourself in the firing line it was in
this movie you had the tooth knocked out
this time
oh yes i i had a concussion whiplash
stitches in my hand dislocated shoulder
yeah there's been a lot of breaks and
sprains and concussions i think the most
psychologically damaging was when i
broke my penis
a few years ago i was i was trying to
backflip a motorcycle and i can't ride a
motorcycle and i came off the ramp i let
go of the bike it goes 20 feet in the
air
and comes down and breaks its handlebars
off in my crotch
so yeah uh you know straight to the
hospital in surgery but
that was like over three years ago and i
still have to catheter twice a day
like a 15 inch tube about the size of a
number two pencil
twice a day a 15-inch two
lucky wife
i gotta be honest like a two-week tube
will probably get the job done
so it still hasn't healed not completely
but i have a 10 month old son so it
still works
oh yeah yeah thank you
well listen uh that's i'm saying the
mashed up penis is a very impressive
injury
we've got 600 people in our audience
tonight so uh let's see
let's see if we can do better than that
uh we'll see who's hurt what
uh hurt feelings right there
have you heard anything have you broken
anything no no never
horse riding anything no no no
bungee gone wrong nothing nothing
nothing
absolutely nothing nothing nothing at
all
i can't help you johnny didn't even
bring you oh you broke something
lady up here's broken something
what were you up to i broke my nose i
walked into a tree
i'm sensing drink was involved was it a
good thing
actually it was um my first week in high
school i was on school camp
it was an introduction to our new peers
in new life at high school i was
blindfolded and it was a trust game
i liked the people you went to school
with that's a really funny game trust me
anyone else had any broken anything oh
injury
i got a rubber stuck up my nose
[Applause]
the how that happened bit of the story
would have been
really good it was his first time
[Laughter]
did you do it yourself or did someone
else shove it up my brother dared me to
put a pencil
up my nose and you know the yellow ones
are the pink
yes do you know them yes yes
yes she told me i couldn't take it out
because it would erase my memories
[Applause]
how old are you six oh
but no permanent damage it depends on
what you call permanent damage
well done all the injured people very
[Applause]
[Music]
good
you